Calma is a very unique community we have
a million and a half underground
residents and 1711 residents we have
become the city of souls
my name is Pat Hatfield and I'm the
retired historian French town of Colma I
am live doing now for 65 years since
1950 we have now 17 cemeteries I call us
the United Nations of cemeteries because
we have a cemetery for everyone we have
for instance we have four Jewish
cemeteries we have a Catholic cemetery a
Greek cemetery and tiles and dairy and
we even have a pet cemetery we have very
things people like Wyatt Earp and Joe
DiMaggio and William Randolph Hearst and
just goes on we inherited hundreds of
thousands of body because during the
gold rush so many gold miners came here
and with them they bought so many
diseases the San Francisco instantly had
27 cemeteries and they were full and the
city fathers said our lamb is be for the
living not for the dead
so an eviction nose was passed in 1914
and the bodies were slowly transferred
here to coma the core residents really
respect our cemeteries but we call the
mark parks that's what they are we
picnic then we walk in them our children
play in them they're just a part of ours
we do have a slower pulse here almost
dead but
[Music]